you are Veronica's main love interest
but you fans for quite a long time and
they're diehard fans really did not like
you I think hate might be I want to talk
about that a little bit the fan reaction
to you for a number of years now we
would do these mothers and Joel silver
put us out in the small circuit where
we'd sign autographs for people that had
only seen one episode and everybody
would always skip me and I'm like I'm
not really like that you know and then
Rob our creator wrote some stuff for me
that made it seem like you know you
could feel for him and his dad was
abusive and stuff like that and then the
old grandma would come up and say I used
to hate you but now I'm not so sure I'm
not so sure as all you get Bryan Bryan
you play dick Casablancas the juiciest
name ever
[Laughter]
dick baby names dick dick Casablancas
and it's so gross public people will
refer to you as they shut out dick and
you don't know you don't know how to
take that right literally like will be
like with the family and all this
somebody's like hey dick and I'm not
sure if I like offended somebody or if
they're like a fan usually you know I
have offended somebody but sometimes
it's a fan you think it was your hair
that got you the job oh I know it was my
hair that got me the job Dan and right
there it is Oh God
I mean how can you not cast that guy's
dick cops about the hair right it's all
about the hair yeah yeah I think it was
amazing it looks like you'd be sued by
Owen Wilson or something
[Applause]